did you see that clutch victory there
that was that was some time pressure uh
that was just a madness that was the
greatest time pressure display i've ever
seen
oh thank you just save a little for pog
champs i'll i'll do my best i'll try not
to let it all out before then how do you
feel so your first game's on tuesday
how are you feeling i was feeling great
i went on a huge tilt today
i went from 11 or i don't remember i
think it was 1100 or like 350
all the way down to 980. okay i mean
that's like
every day for me basically i mean just
add a couple thousand points but
same thing right right right so you're
playing code mika on tuesday um
if you're down for another session
tomorrow we'll we'll leave the sort of
specific preparation for tomorrow i
think she's
mostly a beginner so you're in pretty
good shape
great that's good to hear but um a
couple of things that you know i sort of
want to get done before
we want to obviously get as much you
know get you as warmed up as possible so
we'll do some tactics we'll play some
games we'll play some odds
and obviously i want to polish up your
openings i want to do a quick review of
black and then
do the same thing we did last time but
with the vienna because you're
definitely going to get it
a lot during pot champs okay that sounds
good to me
[Music]
uh maybe if you want to play like a five
minute game or a ten minute game i think
that's
something that you can just to
approximate the pace um
that would be awesome whichever
whichever one you prefer
all right i'm hopping into a five minute
game fantastic
it's just silly and nice yeah i've been
doing a lot of work playing fast
you're a new man i mean just the speed
of wow the pre-move jesus
who are you i know i i can read this
level like a book these days
incredible
very good queen c7
this is this is flawless this is
textbook uh
yeah it but it's it's sometimes it has
been known to fall apart
well the handyman is here the toilet
shall be fixed it will flush again
oh beautiful so this is sort of the
first position where
you're playing on your own and you
remember like what the key ideas are
here
yeah so typically here i'll play this
bishop move b7
exactly and it looks bad right because
you're staring at the pawn but you're
actually preparing
to control the center with d5 yep
perfect
yeah he's terrified of that bishop like
i
am of dentists are you afraid of
dentists
i'm not that of a dancer i was trying to
find something i'm terrified of but i'm
actually not
terrified of too many things oh you're
just too big of a man
dude i'm i'm like huge man i have no
fears
bugs wasps actually if you want to know
um that makes sense so now like you've
played d5
that epon wants to join the d-pawn but
you can't play e5 immediately so
is there any way you can prepare that
um i can move my knight here but then it
will probably just have an exchange
yeah that bishop on g7 that's your heart
and soul yeah
any other pieces that you could delegate
that task
i could bring my broken e8 yeah i like
that idea
and i like that you put this rook on
here because if you put the other rook
on it then
the f8 rook would have been kind of
trapped it also hangs that a7 pawn
that is true okay so he's this guy's
pretty competent
and so
what i looked at here was pushing queen
all the way up to f4
looking to attack that bishop since i
love it that's a good aggressive
energetic move
it's a little risky but it you know it
faces him with the decision and you want
to do as much of that as possible
yeah he's probably he seems like the
kind of guy he likes to stop all the
threats
so this is how you want to play against
people like him he might go queen e3
he seems like a queen trade kind of guy
or queen e5
yeah just if i'm getting the right read
on okay bishop e5
now where do you want to park that queen
because if you're already playing
aggressively you want it preferably to
be in an attacking position
i was looking at b4 that's interesting
that i actually like that move a lot you
could also have gone to g5
um and x-rayed his king but it's really
a matter of taste
okay that makes i'm gonna do b4 since i
was the first one yeah no i like that a
lot and you're continuing
to attack his pawns he's probably going
to go like rook b1
although he actually doesn't have to
defend the b-pawn which is interesting
you're not really attacking it
but there we go okay the next move i was
looking at was pushing this pawn to
d4 excellent opening up your bishop
like i said you're you're an accelerated
dragon natural
i'm i've been really feeling the
accelerated dragon here i like it a lot
it's i mean it's gonna it's gonna bring
you some dubs in blockchains i think
assuming people don't play d4 okay this
guy is playing really well too so
okay so he's attacking your d-pawn and
you have one more piece that you haven't
brought into the game can you combine
the sort of two things together yeah
uh well the my e-rook isn't really doing
anything right now
uh moving my a rook to d8 though that
would give him a free pawn at a7
is that something i should worry about
no so actually that on an a7
it's sort of uh you know it's it's
collateral damage it's the sort of thing
you just have to give up in order to
activate all of your pieces
and if you notice like if he takes the
pawn on a7 his knight gets really out of
place
yeah and uh just that fact alone is
worth giving that pawn over and that a7
pawn is the least important pawn in the
middle game so you shouldn't
you shouldn't give these pun ups if you
can avoid it but uh it's often not the
end of the world
okay and yeah this guy is very
is definitely impressing me in the early
going but you're still in very good
shape here
okay he takes it so you can pretend
basically that nothing happened because
he's going to waste time evacuating his
knight back to b5 and in that time you
can make up
you can make further improvements in
your position
so you can also actually win the pawn
back so notice that he has an undefended
pawn on a2
yeah i was looking at a4 which attacks
his knight and yeah
perfect when a4 when a5 is both good
hopefully he pays attention to the a
pawn and not to his knight but someone
of gomer pyle's caliber
oh i mean you you know you know gomer i
mean that guy he's full of tricks
you know it's like the most interesting
man in the world he can defend both his
knight and his apon at the same time
he is the most interesting man in the
world
bishop c4 would be a really good move
for him this position would attack your
queen activate his bishop
okay bishop takes d4 now you have a you
can make a dangerous move here you can
threaten checkmate and you can also
evacuate your queen while you're at it
yeah it's bringing it all the way to d5
yeah
and you're not going to track might him
he's going to see that he's going to
probably play f3
but that induces a weakness on his king
side so that's a
small victory for you okay
oh my god the narrative jinx man the
gm's do this when i when as soon as i
compliment somebody they blunder
some crazy [ __ ] it's literally the next
move after you pay them a compliment
it's actually impressive that you're
able to do that every single time
i i'm going to i'm going to pay someone
to make a compilation of this because
it's it's getting it's getting pretty
absurd
i i honestly i think it would be worth
it to like go through the vods and find
every example of one of these moments
because usually when i'm tilted or i'm
frustrated my way of expressing
frustration is to say how good my
opponent is
and that's the moment they blunder a
rock or blunter into checkmate
that's a i mean he played a really high
level up until there
so let me just quickly i have like two
instructive moments to talk about then
you can jump in for one more warm-up
game
there we go so i'll be quick
yeah so okay so queen c7 beautiful
zero complaints here as to your play
bishop b7 d5
this is uh bishop d4 is a really nice
move by him most people
they don't really notice that you're
threatening e5
so rookie 8 prepares e5 queen f4 is a
very nice move now just to expand on the
move queen g5 the reason i like this
move
is because it x-rays the game but that's
not the only thing it does if you look
at this g2 pawn what are you threatening
here if it's
let's make a random move for white what
would you do
i would have pushed my d pawn which
threatens mate and
if he blocks it i win a knight exactly
now what if he blocks with a knight
uh how is the position and when when
there's a lot of traffic like this you
want to really understand which pieces
are now undefended how is the position
changed as a result of the last move
he's blocking his queen
so i just take the bishop bingo the
queen is blocking the bishop
now i'm going to turn this around and
i'm going to ask you a challenging
question let's say you're playing white
and you plunder this can white
actually avoid losing a piece here
if i was a little bit more sadistic the
answer would be no and i'd just make you
sit there for 15 minutes but the answer
is yes
i have a funny story about that but uh
first i want you to come up with a move
okay
i'm assuming it has to be an attack on
the queen yes you're absolutely correct
and it has to defend against checkmate
in the so
i think the only move that does that
is bringing um
i looked at blocking with the bishop but
that doesn't attack the queen right
so one of the misconce so one of the
things people often miss right when
you're attacking a pawn
uh oh yeah you just put you're pushing
that pawn up to f4 huh
exactly yep so it's it's hard to see
this because
you're opening up the queen's defense of
the pawn that your brain is like well i
gotta push the pawn up or i gotta
intercept the queen but you can also
defend the pawn that's being attacked
very good yeah so the story is i was
teaching my first ever chess camp
and that does exist believe it or not
and this was like 2014. i i didn't have
much teaching experience
and i was really nervous i was preparing
all these positions as mapping every
minute out
and so i finally you know come to the
front and i'm like okay we're going to
do we're going to start with a couple of
puzzles
and this is like 10 kids and they're
pretty talented so i really want to do a
good job
and i set up the first position right
and i i set it up wrong i
i forgot to include a pawn and that
particular pawn
changed completely the landscape of the
position so the solution that i had
intended didn't work
and i'm sitting there for 15 minutes
literally i sat there for a few times i
was like man these
i was i was told that these kids are
talented um
okay i'm gonna give them like five more
minutes and then i finally
i was like thinking about freaking pig
turtles and then i finally decided to
look at the position i was like
holy [ __ ] where is the a pun and uh
i managed to get out of that situation
without them knowing that i set the
position of prom because i wouldn't have
made that out of the room in one piece
but uh anyways no i mean they were
really good kids they would have
forgiven me but
my ego didn't allow it no of course not
and that's just extremely embarrassing
oh yeah wasting 15 minutes of time of
kids at chess camp just unthinkable so
anyways that was one moment the other
moment
was just i wanted to ask you this why is
let's say he goes a3 that actually would
have been a very high level move
um what would have happened if you take
on b2
uh let's see i take on b2
he's going to have to move that knight
or although he doesn't it's protected by
bishops
right he'd probably move the knight
somewhere
let's see so he has
three he has basically four ways of
trapping your queen here
yeah well it starts with the knight
though right or does it start with the
rook
both you can start with both pieces and
both trap the queen now if you start
with a rook which rook do you want to
put on b1
the a rook right oh no so compare the
two which
like which one of them leaves something
undefended and allows the queen to
escape
that'd be the other rook because it
hangs that pawn on a3 exactly so this is
sort of the conventional way but if you
move the knife you got to think about
which escape squares you want to try to
cover right and the queen at the moment
has only one escape score so you just
need to cover that
escape square than i either by
intercepting it or by
defend protecting with the knight
so the only escape square is that b6
right
bingo where's the knight oh
you take on d's yeah you take on d5
yep that would be that would absolutely
work you could even go knight to a4
which is a double attack on the queen
but that's not what matters what matters
is that you cover the b6 square okay
okay so or even knight b5 uh which
would not cover the b6 but it would
intercept the queen's access to it
yeah and it's still being attacked so
your queen is the piece you always want
to keep an eye on and when you're about
to take a pawn like this it's not that
you never want to take it
but you got to be extra careful about
about not getting your queen trapped and
if you're in trouble
one way and one set of tricks involves
you know quote-unquote blundering upon
like this
because you know your opponents will
often just take upon like this
impulsively
and you may have cooked up a way to trap
the queen and that could be one way to
turn a game around
other than that that was fantastic we
were 88 you won the pawn back now this
pawn
is a better pawn to capture because the
queen has two different escape routes
and white can't cover both of them at
the same time
and uh what would have been white's best
move here last question
really white's only almost white's only
good way to defend against me
yeah it's only pushing that pawn right
f3 yep and that would have blunted your
your battery but that would have
weakened his king a little bit so you
have some compensation for the pawn
but bishop f6 was a move of
unprecedented genius and
yeah okay maybe one more game and then
we'll
launch into some some drills sounds good
i'm happening
perfect i don't know if you want to put
your 1 000 rating at jeopardy but
i i've already lost it twice today i
think i'm more than fine losing it again
that's the attitude i like to hear the
dutch here we go
yeah so i actually feel really confident
playing the dutch
oh it's a great opening yeah i find that
my highest i think it's probably my
highest win
rate it's just pointing the touch it's
as good as it gets and it's and it's
unduly unjustly criticized actually at a
high level it's it's pretty hard even
for gm's to get a good position against
the dutch
so h4 what he just played is a really
good move but he just he didn't follow
it up correctly
he's looking to get a pawn break right
yeah i mean i'll show you afterward this
is like the best line against it
i'll show you what the the correct
approach is but you you need to really
analyze this carefully to know it
okay okay so
the position hasn't really changed what
i want to do here i still want to open
up
on e5 yeah you want to prepare it so i
go d6 then i'm pushing e5
well okay so he goes e4 himself and now
you have to react dynamically to what
he's done
yeah i mean he gave me this fork oh no
yeah but taking was still correct i mean
you have to release the tension
and now you have to ask yourself like
the obvious thing is do you want to
trade knights on e4 do you have to
do you gain anything from taking on e4
and if the answer is no then you can
just develop your pieces that's what
people often don't realize is like
let that traffic just be there on e4 let
him take your night
so how would you develop yours in the
most natural way c6
excellent wait did i just compliment
[ __ ]
okay so again your opponents say they
are playing well
so he wants to blast open your king side
and there's basically two ways of
thinking about this you can actually you
can try to actively prevent him from
doing that or you can counter strike
and counter counter-striking can be the
most effective form of defense do you
see a counter-strike here
i was looking at pinning knight to queen
taking pawn
d4 that's not and i'll show you why
after the game but you want something
that carries a little bit more weight
you want to attack one of his pieces
and you don't forget it because this is
your main idea
you've been preparing this for three
moves now i still do want to just push
through this
that's an independently good move
because you're occupying the center look
at his knight on f3 and his bishop on d3
what can you tell me about them
uh they're in a very forkable position
they're in an extremely workable
position
and if he plays this correctly then he
should sacrifice a piece and get an
attack for it but that's a very very
difficult
sort of thing to orchestrate
all right i got my red pen out now
you're now you're screwed
oh okay
talk about 10.
yeah so if i were him i might actually
take the pawn on g6 and leave the bishop
on f4 sacrifice it
in order to open up your king side okay
so he takes this way
ah but he can actually save his piece
but we'll see if he finds it
so he can give you a check on c4 with
his light square bishop and remove it
from its workable position
don't tell him he's in the stream he's
definitely in the stream
i always have this paranoia it's a
perpetual paranoia
but then i learn i sometimes will say
like a bad move just as a test
i have another story about that but let
me shut off we have we have work to do
yeah it's serious business time daniel
it is
i don't know i've lost my russian edge
thank you shea bomb
for the prime okay but i think he's
freaking out
i think that his time consumption
indicates to me that he's he's
okay okay but you want to find the best
i mean resigning is an option here but
you want to find the best
now remember there are three ways to
deal with the check you can move your
king
you can take the piece that's giving the
check which you can here or you can
intercept the check
yeah i was thinking block is better but
then if i do that i lose the control
over
e5 because i'd have to block with bishop
okay but you lose the rook's control
over e5
how many times is e5 controlled
nonetheless uh
two attackers i see okay and two
defenders
exactly and that's a good move because
you develop your bishop now he can trade
queens that's not a big deal you get an
end game
but you at least you've got all of your
pieces developed
all right and you're also continually
attacking his pieces so you're
you're forcing him to spend a lot of
time working through the chaos here
okay i think you have nothing to work on
is counting because i thought
by blocking the rook i would lose the
exchange but yeah right i see i would
come out
on top yeah it's kind of sometimes
unintuitive that
you know equal number of attackers and
defenders is good for the defenders
um and and there are things that change
that obviously there's tactics that
you know that change but but in general
that's the rule of thumb and
i'll note that down maybe i'll be able
to come up with some positions on that
okay uh i was looking at just pushing
this pawn again it attacks the knight
and attacks b2
fantastic and he's uncastled here so
it's very very good that you're now
grabbing the initiative
thank you the screeching weasel
and now his knight has no good squares
either he can't go to g5
man this dutch is in your hands it's
just uh
i don't know how to describe it i'm
tongue-tied
okay that's a pretty savvy move actually
so in this position do i just want to
take that pawn then just get something
out of this
um you can take the pawn but i would say
that your top priority is probably to
renew the attack on his knight and what
do you need to do to
do in order to accomplish that i need to
get the rook out of this x-ray
or you need to defend the rook now in
doing that you also want to activate
another one of your pieces
so which piece do you think that might
be um
i see i can bring my knight in at d4 it
attacks the queen
protects the rook but that allows him to
take on d4 that gives his knight an out
i would use
i would use your queen and i would use
your queen to defend your rook
but while you're doing that you might as
well bring your queen to a really nice
spot in the center of the board
okay so all the way up to d5 then bingo
because and does it make sense that you
don't want to trade knights you want his
knight
to to not have an escape route because
it's going to have to go back to like h2
or g1 which is pretty disastrous
okay and then you have a really big
attack now
if he does that i wouldn't even bother
taking the pawn on v2
i would look for moves that are even
more active and i would understand
okay when his knight moves back like
that which squares can you now access
maybe with your pieces your knight
that can give you a very strong
attacking move potentially yeah
so then that's that d4 i wanted to play
yeah you're just gonna crush him here
also can actually win his knight funnel
enough because he put it on
he put it on h4 i didn't even notice
that when he moves his queen depending
on where he moves it
you can actually trap that knight okay
so he's given you a chance to do
something even better
so i looked at this fork at c2 i imagine
this is the best that's gonna get
i believe so okay cool
well this is better than roses on
valentine's day
it's the best gift anyone can give me
just watching a fork in action
uh you know what would be even better is
if he moves his king to oh
[Music]
i was going to say if he moved it to
like f1 then i'd also get the picture on
the bishop
but then you would get your rook on e6
okay so this is an important moment
actually you got to be very careful here
i call this the umbrella method you see
his pawn on g6
if his pawn on g6 were not there your
king would be in check it would be nasty
you want to make sure that you are
letting his pawn on g6 act as the
protection to your king
how can you ensure that that's the case
by pushing my own pawn
now would you push it to h6 or h5 uh
it looks like h6 is the safest
well are you sure about that yeah i mean
go go h6
no i see because then the bishop takes
and i can't control that square right
now anyway
okay so h5 okay the actual reason h5 is
better isn't because bishop takes but
we'll talk about that after the game
that's that's a pretty instructional
moment i think
oh that's a genius move did you see that
queen sacrifice that was just sexy
that was just he had 18 seconds my
[ __ ] heart breaks for him man that
[ __ ] happens to me
oh god now another discover check oh god
oh you're just mopping the floor here
it's not looking good for the boy wonder
i'm just going to keep delivering checks
until it's over i think
yep you could have also taken his night
but you've you've lined your pockets
enough here i think
you can go after all the obviously queen
it's all good
i i've perfected that i mean with 0.1
seconds you make the most absurd move
yeah and you know what what's even the
dirtiest trick and
i had a student who did that and i shut
that [ __ ] down immediately
he would so his opponent would get to
one second and this isn't all this has
existed for
20 years now when i was growing up and
playing on the internet chess club which
is like the old server
people were doing that you offer your
opponent a draw
and then you immediately checkmate him
like before he has a chance to react to
it
you immediately give checkmate or you
make a move and he loses on time
that's like for a chess player i know
people are like what
but for chess player that's like a huge
insult like that is like
next level trolling um did you give them
a
harsh spanking take them over your knee
yeah i that that stuff just doesn't fly
with me
like you you try that [ __ ] or you tell
me you do that during a lesson i'm
shutting that down immediately
you're gonna play like a like a
respectful russian schoolboy
if you're part of the nerdsy army okay
so let me invite you to another board
you said i could have taken his knight
yes you could have trapped his knight
okay so then just
all right i think i see so just take its
check he has to take
that i take back yeah and we'll we'll
run through that line so this move h4
right he i was surprised he played it
and the best move for him here is
actually h5
very difficult to understand why this is
a good move
because it seems to blunder upon now
which which way would you take the spawn
if you were black here
you just take with the the knight right
because it is
well that's not the main reason right
because the bishop is still not such a
great piece it's biting on granite
but yes you're right the other reason is
you don't want to take with a pawn
because
you're probably going to castle king
side and you don't want to ruin your
structure like that right you don't want
to leave this pawn week i'm not
as you know i don't really give a [ __ ]
about pawn structure but i give a [ __ ]
about it if
if it relates to your king safety um
and after knight takes h5 there's a
crazy move rook takes h5 this is an
exchange sacrifice
and after you take the rook how does how
do you think he follows up he takes with
the queen delivering a check
right you have to move the kanga now
he takes the pawn delivering another
check bingo
and white is not winning here it's not
mate but white has a very strong
long-term attack against black's gang
and you're only up in exchange right
you're not up like five brooks here
right so according to my analysis and
it's funny because i analyzed this
recently with
with uh my highest rated student and he
was preparing against the dutch
white is white is better here but it's
playable i mean
it's a very double-edged position in any
case he played knight f3 first you
castle now one question i have for you
is you start with rook e8 which is to my
knowledge a little bit
awkward is there any reason that you
didn't start with
and let me check this right now actually
because he played something that your
opponents might actually play let me
let me actually look at my notes to see
if i analyze this
yeah so after castles okay the best move
is is to start with d6
and the best way to understand why
is that if you move a rook to e there's
just something about this move that
looks very awkward right
your the only purpose of this move is to
prepare e5 whereas if you play a move
like d6 you want to start with the most
flexible move
this move not only prepares e5 it opens
up your bishop it controls a little bit
of the center
does that kind of make sense yeah makes
sense so you want to start with d6
and then you want to play rookie and
then nicely so just a very small
nitpicky note
okay okay so bishop d3 now if he would
have given you a check
how would you have reacted here block
with the pawn e6
excellent now can you tell me why you
wouldn't play this move this is a
dreadful mistake
uh i mean it looks like [ __ ] like yeah
you're completely locked in now because
that bishop
can just keep that locked yeah it looks
like hot sewage but how do you actually
how do you actually punish that oh
you're not you're not gonna get off the
hook just by telling me it looks like
[ __ ] like you're some grandmaster
you're gonna tell me why it's fed i
would guess that you try and bring that
f3 knight into the attack here it has a
nice square at g5
now you're speaking a language i love
and understand so actually knight e5 is
even stronger
and there's a kind of a mind-blowing
reason why and this will lead me to a
very important point that i want you to
apply in pogchamps and
i think it's going to stand behind some
of your success okay so
what is the first thing you see in this
position it's the fork if that's
if f7 isn't defended it's a fork and you
win the queen so you have to defend that
with
the rook exactly but giving this fork
let me make an analogy
let's say you've just won the lottery
and you live close to the
lottery office i don't know where you're
cashing the lottery and you decide to
bike
to the lottery office to cash in your
million dollar
ticket and on the way you see a hundred
dollar bill that lies on the ground
and you're like holy [ __ ] so you you got
so excited that you drop your lottery
ticket it flies away into the ocean
and you pick up the 100 bill and you're
like i'm awesome
so knight f7 check is like favoring a
hundred dollar bill over a lottery
ticket
now when you have a situation like this
you always have to understand
and put things into context what are you
actually winning with white by playing
this move
uh so i mean you're only winning the
rook you're giving two pieces for a rook
here
two pieces for a rook to be more
accurate so rook takes f7 bishop f7
what what is this called you're trapped
you can now just play that pawn
but what is white up right now it's not
a rook and it's not two pieces
in exchange but black's gonna win a
second piece very probably
and even if black didn't win a second
piece upbeat up in exchange
is great but it's not amazing and here
white can do something
to be completely winning and it's a very
strong attacking move that i just showed
you in this very game
white can play this move again with even
greater effect oh you just push that
pawn up
and you do that to open up the h val you
as you already pointed out black ting is
no escape
and after knight takes h5 white has a
very pretty mating sequence
um i want you to think about it and it
all occurs with checks
that's a hint that i'm going to give you
so from this point forward it all
occurs with checks all occurs with
checks no from this point forward and
it's forced mate
and it's a little challenging but i
think you got this so the first check
that you deliver has to be g6 with the
knight right
yep and you do that in order to
reposition this h-bond
and then you deliver a check with the
queen here on
h5 okay you're on the right track but do
you need to sacrifice the queen
i guess you do the rook first and the
queen yeah so in general even if queen
takes work
you're you're playing to win games not
to paint pictures so
it's it's important to give yourself an
abundance of caution so rook takes
queen takes would not have worked and
i'll show you why in just a second now
what
now you take with the queen delivering
another i have the pitiful defensive
move bishop h6
uh you just take with the queen yeah
this is a pathetic i mean look at black
pieces it's like you haven't made any
moves
um so the reason that queen h5 wouldn't
have worked
is because after bishop h6 white may
actually still be winning white
is still winning but after rook h6
black's king has a new lease in life
so the lesson here and i'll show you
where you could have applied this in the
game
is that when you see something like
mediocre like you can win an exchange
you want to take 10 15 seconds and put
things into context and ask yourself
whether you can't go for more
and don't go crazy like if you're not
sure or you can do something risky maybe
it's worth just winning the exchange
but at least put it some thought okay so
bishop d3 does that make sense yeah and
i'll give you a chance to do that so
bishop f6
e5 is great now knight takes d4 would
have been a bad idea because
you haven't completed your development
and your king is wide open which means
after knight d4 bishop d4
i noticed two things i notice you're
king and i notice the fact that this
bishop is undefended and how can white
combine the two things
he delivers a check i have to move he
wins that bishop with queen
exactly yeah yeah and that's just
crushing so it's very important that you
and e5 you're counter-struck here
bishop e6 is good e4 is perfect
this is example number one your eyes are
drawn as our mind to the pawn
but i tell myself here i just went upon
it he can move his rook and he gets
another tempo
but i can do a lot more than a pawn
cause his king is uncastled his queen is
susceptible to this move
and so queen d5 is much stronger
and after knight h4 how could you have
trapped his knight if you wanted to
your move was the best but nonetheless
yeah you just push the pawn right he has
no more squares exactly push the pawn up
to g5
but instead he went knight t4 and then
the second instance of where
you could have applied this principle is
here so you instantly played knight
takes a1
which i understand now in russia this
would have gotten your
you know one of your less essential
organs
uh tampered with but i will be a little
bit more forgiving
because i get the appeal of that could
you have
but let's say you can't take the rook
forget about that for a second could you
propose something stronger
uh so what i looked at here is pushing
the queen to d3
actually that is probably yeah that is a
good move
that is a great start the king goes to
d1 now be very careful
okay um
[Music]
yeah i muted myself he is he is sharp
right now he's seeing stuff
like he's never seen before i'm pretty
optimistic well now
if i well now i can take the rokin that
now blocks the
king okay but look at the whole board
how is the position
changed as a result of queen e3 have you
left anything on defender
is undefended so immediately you're like
okay i need to move my rook and i need
to do it with tempo
how can i do it
looks like the best square for the rook
would be
right behind the queen here at d6 and
then taking the bishop
exactly so he has to bring his queen
back and then you have a great choice
you could now you can take the rook and
you win the entire rook and you force
the queen tray that's a much better
version of what you did
so that would be one example and the
other thing you could do what would i
actually do in this position
um i you could actually start with the
move rook d8
which might seem like weird to be like
why of all the things you could do you
do this move
well the point is that if his bishop
moves away black to play
you have to choose one of about 18 ways
to checkmate him
yeah god uh wow
what are the king's escape squares so
right now the king
only has f or he only has um
take the square away that's it
i don't see how we do that
oh i just delivered the same check i
delivered at d3
exactly or you can deliver one at c4
that's why i put the rook on da by the
way so that the king
can't come out come over here and so the
king can come back to do you want
okay or you could even deliver it here
so with when you sense the mate uh
be methodical where can the king escape
how can i take away these escapes and if
you can't find a way to do it
don't panic and go nuts even taking the
rook here is better because i see a lot
of people they
they can't see the mid and then they
just do something absolutely wild
um you can also play e3 just throw a
pawn at him and weaken him even further
and if he defends with a rook on d1 what
can you do here
it's still delivering the same check
right it's still made
nothing changed and again the point of
rookie is to force him
to cover up the d1 square where he
previously could have escaped okay
so okay so all right that makes sense
yeah so
yeah that was the move that i would have
actually played rook t what rook did he
can avoid made for a little longer but
uh but but not for very long
[Music]
you